So, Anthropic just released Sonnet 4.6
today, and the benchmarks are really
good. So good, in fact, it's actually
beating out Opus 4.6 in some areas while
coming in at a 40% cheaper price point.
But, do we really care about those
particular benchmarks? And more
importantly, where should you be
deploying Sonnet 4.6 moving forward?
We're going to talk about all that more
in this video. So, the first Sonnet 4.6
feature I want to talk about is their
new context window length. It is now 1
million tokens. Now, some people might
jump at this and say, "Awesome. That's
great." But if you've been watching my
channel at all, you know about the idea
of context rot. That's the idea that as
we fill up the context window, and
really once we hit about 100,000 150,000
tokens, the effectiveness of our model
tends to drop significantly, which calls
into question how useful is a giant
context window. So, Enthropic speaks to
this a little bit. So they say, "Hey,
the new context window, it's big enough
to hold entire code bases, but more
importantly, it can reason effectively
across all that context." The
implication there being, oh no, it's
huge, but you know, you won't deal with
context rot right away. And what they
use as proof is this vending bench arena
evaluation, and we'll go into benchmarks
in a second. Basically, they have it run
a simulated business over time, and they
say, "Hey, cuz it did so good, this
means the context window rot issue isn't
as much of a problem anymore."
H I would take that with a grain of
salt. So, I think getting bigger context
windows is good, but it doesn't
necessarily mean it's as good as you
would think. So, we'll hold off till I
see more evidence that this isn't a
problem. So, now let's take a look at
the benchmarks. And we have all the
Frontier models on here. We have Sonnet
4.6 over here on the left. Now, compared
to Sonnet 4.5, Sonnet 4.6 is frankly a
huge leap board. It crushes it on
virtually every single test. And when we
compare Sonnet 4.6 to Opus 4.6, remember
Opus 4.6 6 is a much larger, more
expensive model. It actually wins in
some cases. And the two I'd like to call
out because it's two places where Sonnet
4.6 beats everybody is a gentic
financial analysis and office tasks.
Now, office tasks in computer use in
general is really what Anthropic is
pushing with Sonnet 4.6. And you see
here in this clip they released, that's
all they're demoing. So, a lot of this
has to do with Claude Co-work. And what
they're constantly pushing is that, hey,
Sonet 4.6
is really really good at a using your
computer, b being able to browse the
web, and c being able to execute again
these office tasks. Think of things like
Excel or email or things of that nature.
More practical use cases for I would say
your average everyday AI user, not
necessarily some hardcore coders. Now,
speaking of coding and more technical
tasks, Sonet 4.6 still holds its own.
So, when we look at agentic terminal
coding and agentic coding, 4.6 6 by the
numbers is basically as good as Opus 4.5
while again being 40% cheaper. And we
compare it to the other Frontier models
like Gemini 3 Pro and 5.2. Again, it is
doing pretty good. So, here's another
chart I found on Twitter that shows a
Sonnet 4.6 versus Opus 4.6.
Head-to-head, same benchmarks you just
saw, just easier to see. And I think
this one is important because now the
question becomes, when should I use
Sonnet versus Opus? Because unless
you're on the max plane at 200 bucks a
month where you can just kind of spam
Opus and not worry about it, for those
of you who are a little more token
conscious and costconscious, now there's
a real decision to be made because there
are instances where Sonnet is just going
to do just fine. And so we can see over
here on the right where is Opus the
strongest, agentic search, novel problem
solving and terminal coding and sonnet
leads in scale tool use, financial
analysis and office task. So I think
looking at this you start to get a clear
picture of like all right when should I
still be using Opus and I think that's
when you're dealing with more complex
problems if you're dealing with more
novel coding issues but if you're doing
more everyday mundane things that you
know is not going to require the full
throughput of everything anthropic has
to offer well then maybe we should be
using sonnet because it's just so dang
cheap especially again if you're rather
costconscious and the cost thing cannot
be dismissed out of hand because
historically anthropic API cost have
been rather expensive. So over here on
the model pricing page, there's nothing
special about the Opus 4.6 and Sonet 4.6
pricing, they pretty much follow the
same form those two models have been
using for quite a while now. And
Enthropic echoes that sentiment at the
end of their article where they say, "We
find Opus 4.6 remains the strongest
option for task that demand the deepest
reasoning such as codebase refactoring,
coordinating multiple agents in a
workflow, and problems where getting it
just right is paramount." So Opus 4.6 6
is the nuclear bomb option and we've
kind of had to use the nuke for
everything for the last few weeks just
because of the disparity between Opus
4.6 and Sonnet 4.5, but now we finally
have a scalpel which I think is awesome
news. And of note, Sonnet 4.6 is now the
default option when you're using the
Claude web app. So definitely check it
out. I think they're really pushing the
Claude co-work side of this with Sonnet
4.6 because again, I think if you are
pretty deep in the AI stuff, you don't
even realize how much of a bubble you're
in. Like if you're using a clawed max p
plan and paying $100, $200 a month for
essentially unlimited opus usage, like
you are not like you kind of are the
target consumer, but at the same time
you're such a small percentage of the
market. So I don't think it's a surprise
that they're really moving into this
co-work office usage space, right? It's
almost like enterprise light and
Anthropic, if you've been paying
attention, is really deep in the
enterprise space, especially when you
consider their size versus something
like OpenAI. So, really cool update.
Glad it's here. Let me know in the
comments what you thought.